mal bruce un va-t-en-guerre à me
rendormir anton migranten la malle bruce
s'en va-t-en guerre
l'europe un
[Applaudissements]
couac est ce que ce serait casimir veux
tu s'il te plaît cessé de chanter ça me
fait gonfler les oreilles nos cinq ans
il reviendra à pâques à me rendormir
anton mire open il reviendra à patins ou
à la trinité
casimir dix mois casimir qui ce monsieur
malbrouck dont tu parle tout le temps je
ne connais pas léonard tué en ignorant
et quand est-ce qu'il viendra monsieur
malbrouck un tu pourras me le présenter
peut-être tu sais les amis de mes amis
sont mes amis
mais il n'existe pas c'est le héros
d'une vieille chanson prend fait ce que
je lis m'a apprise ont très bien très
bien totalement ignorants comme tu es tu
ne s'est peut-être pas non plus pourquoi
je chante cette chanson 1 et bien c'est
parce que c'est bientôt pâques à
l'est je suppose que tu ne sais pas non
plus ce qu'est pas qu'à
moi bon et bien là qu'un c'est le jour
où les cloches viennent au dessus de
l'île et pondent des oeufs dans tout le
jardin non tu es fou qu'un séminaire
ce ne sont pas les cloches qui pondent
des oeufs ce sont les poules mais non
mais écoutez c'est bien placé pour le
savoir enfin j'adore les oeufs mais
j'adore encore plus les poules coûtant
habituellement peut-être mais le jour de
pâques ce sont les cloches et les jeunes
se casse pas en tendant à non non non
parce que ce jour-là ce jour là bas ils
doivent être exceptionnellement solide à
et les cloches font très attention de
laisser tomber les délicatement dans les
buissons en casimir bien sûr tu ne
manques pas de moi ah non absolument pas
mais alors il faut vite regarder si les
clans j'arrive à lui des piges nous
peut-être son talent tout près d'ici par
les montées quoi passement vita
c'est une très bonne idée
j'avais pas pensé sont peut-être déjà là
à temps
alors on regarde bien fait attention au
new age qui risque de les cacher
pour l'instant je ne vois rien
attends je vais voir là bas
alors
oh la la oulalala
ouhlala toi qu'est-ce qui vient 4 15
meilleurs une énorme claque courant
vient sans doute pour te voir un petit
on sait que roma dont 11 à pois bleus
quoi ouais ma maman celle futé
exactement je te laisse avec elle bon
après midi
olalala vendu sa chute et
casimir leone avons peu d'entrées
bonjour ma grosses cloches en chocolat
des îles
ma grosse cloche un chocolat des
léonards montois
vont vous n'en voulez pas mademoiselle
futé non voyons léonard c'est bien vrai
c'est vrai absolument exact pour que ma
belle tu ta grosses cloches en chocolat
désir parce que casimir m'a dit que les
cloches volante allait faire une escale
ici spécialement dans l'île il nous
semblait serait tombé d eux dans les
buissons est ce que c'est vraiment c'est
à peu près ça allait anna mais sais-tu
d'où vient cette coutume des oeufs de
pâques
je trouve que c'est une très bonne
habitude mais ici tout ce que je sais de
ce et bien autrefois pendant le carême
qui était d'une durée de 40 jours avant
pâques on n'avait pas la permission de
manger des
livres coutu
alors on les mettait de côté on les
faisait cuire et puis on les payait en
rouge en verre en bleu et puis le jour
de pâques dans chaque famille on
organisait une distribution de décorer
et maintenant et maintenant que ce sont
les cloches qui les apportent et les
enfants organisent partout dans les
villes dans les maisons dans les jardins
des grandes chasses aux oeufs parce que
naturellement les clans jettent leur jeu
par les fenêtres et les intéresse dans
les salons elle naturellement et
naturellement il devrait y avoir une
clanche qui jette un grand panier 2 dans
ma main ici ah oui les renards mais
cécile est le couvercle de tam albienne
ouvert et je ne vous tombe pas sur le
tâte jeannerat
alors vraiment ces cloches de pâques
sont très intelligent très très
intelligent
bonjour ma chère aide mais on se porte
notre botaniste très très bien monsieur
du snav cironneau la main
que malaxer les vous lâche est raide
mais bien c'est une préparation spéciale
pour 1,9 que je ne fais pas pour casimir
de la crème de marrons de la choucroute
du sucre des piments rouges et un peu
tard il a donné beaucoup de mal pour ce
gros balourd enfin je vous laisse à
votre cuisine à plus tard non mais non
mais non monsieur du sabre revenus oui
oui vous n'êtes pas censé ignorer que
c'est bientôt pâques oui je n'ignore pas
évidemment bien alors j'ai l'intention
d'organiser une grande chasse aux oeufs
pour léonard casimir et tous les ans à
les enfants sont ravis c'est très bien
marché rennes mais oui alors soyez
gentil monsieur du stock donnez moi un
coup de main parce que j'aurais pas tant
tout finir ah bon mais je n'y comprends
absolument rien mais on ne veut pas que
vous avez mais si mais si tu tenais
asseyez-vous là vous allez voir c'est
très simple que doit les peurs voilà
vous prenez tout c'est eux oui voila
voila le prince oui oui les couleurs oui
voilà et je pars et vous ping et vous
croyez que ce n'est pas déshonorant pour
un artiste peintre de faire ce travail
là mais non mais non pas du tout et
quand vous aurez terminé vous les
placerait dans ces petits ni la hadda
que vous voyez très bien aussi que ne
remplit pas les cacher
et puis en plus après toutes les colères
que vous avez eue contre casimir vous
lui devait bien ça j'ai jamais de colère
contre kazim jawad mais j'ai seulement
essayé de lui faire comprendre en
insistant un petit peu je lave ou de ne
pas prendre mais les oeuvres d'art pour
pour des petits fous
c'est bien pour une fois vous serez
ravis qu'ils les mangent
la voilà on ça ira comme ça
voilà voilà vous avez terminé monsieur
dû se terminer bien
n'oubliez pas de conserver quelques
oeufs de compte frais pour léonard et il
ne les aime qu'au naturel
saleh elles sont passées
alors léonard ouais tu vas à l'avant du
jardin et tu fouilles de kiosques oui
moi je vais sur la gauche vers la cage à
poules et l'aube enfin d'accord on y va
martin ya j'en ai déjà un au diable ou
un ses intentions venez m'aider les
enfants
encore un
bon encore en ici
3,4 au haut qu'il est gros celui là on
l'a
elle devait être énorme c'est aux
cloches
voilà et dieu regarde léonard j'en ai
déjà si ça et vous les enfants vous en
avez trouvé beaucoup oui mais voilà
qu'il ressemble à aucun autre ah non non
léonard celui ci est pour moi d'ailleurs
il y à mon nom dessus c'est bon bon bon
mais moi enfin j'aurais préféré trouver
une poule c'est encore meilleur léonard
qui m'avait promis de ne plus jamais
mangé de couleurs
d'ailleurs qu'il a une superbe
collection d'offres a gobé pendant ce
temps là je vais manger le mien
et je l'aimerai paris spécialement
bouge-toi monza et messieurs
ont vraiment leur tous les deux vous
êtes formidables est patent
époustouflant oui mais vous ne devriez
pas vous en tenir là ah bon que nous dû
dire eh bien pendant que nous mangeons
nozari mademoiselle futaie pourrais m'en
préparer un second comme celui ci et
vous vous pourriez nous chanter une
chanson si l'occasion et bien écoute
casimir je vais t'étonner j'accepte
musique comme d'hab
[Musique]
j'ai chassé le lézard vert pendant trois
jours au concours j'ai jouer à saute pas
loin avec un check raise dix morts je
suis très snob chaque jour je code un
gros oeuf d'autruche à mon petit
déjeuner j'ai chanté un opéra dans la
rue à tombouctou trouver les trésors cas
dans un musée du pcot les gens
s'arrachent mais autographes on a
reconnu dans une rue de mon quartier je
suis un champion de la sculpture
[Musique]
un
jeu
fait lécher devrait en peinture je suis
le plus grand le plus beau le plus fort
je connais le fils du frère de la
belle-soeur de marquis c'est un homme de
qualité la preuve c'est qu'il me l'a dit
il est très snob comme moi il colle un
gros atout truchat son petit déjeuner il
sait parler ce trust nord avec un accent
anglais
moi j'y arrive au mieux avec la samah
seillier
j'ai lu talent c'est évident de toute ma
rue je suis la célébrité jeu
suis un champion de la sculpture
[Musique]
heureux
je
fait des chefs-d'oeuvre vente peinture
je suis le plus grand le plus beau le
plus fort mais il m'arrive quelquefois
de faire un rêve un peu fou je m'appelle
monsieur durand et j'ai les mêmes eaux
que
jeanne supplice mort alors je colle un
petit oeuf de poule qui me rend tous des
primaires
matin quand je m'éveille j'oublie mon
rêve et c'est bien je vois ma canne mon
chapeau et mon costume italien
ch redevient ce nom à leur jeu comme un
gros oeuf d'autruche à mon p'tit déj
[Musique]
o
1 poussins